what did you think about bezos going to
space does that does that move you at
all are you
into the billionaire space race these
space cowboys i got to play this clip
from bezos today
did you i mean we watched it on the
podcast um hang on here
jeff were you following jeff bezos go
off into space i i've been following it
so i didn't have the uh
the ticker on my phone so to speak but
uh but yeah it's
it's pretty uh interesting i've been
calling him a space cowboy i'm gonna
show you this clip he's wearing a
freaking cowboy hat here we go
and then i also i want to thank
every amazon employee and every amazon
customer
because you guys paid for all this so
seriously for every amazon customer out
there
and every amazon employee thank you from
the bottom of my heart very much
so there you go up and down he did it
today
um is that an appropriate hat like
what's is a daniel boone like
who is
okay we know how you feel go back and
watch the pbd podcast that you can find
out exactly how gerard felt about the
shape of blue origins rocket that went
up into space we'll just leave it
use your own imagination but what do you
think i mean god when you have all this
money
and and they probably do have some great
intentions of what they want to do i
mean
this is going to be a business space
tourism is going to be a thing 200 grand
to go up and back
yeah um but i mean the cowboy hat the
whole thing
yeah it was nice of him to thank his 16
hour employees
do you think that rubbed like the
hard-working amazon employees that are
in the warehouses and the drivers do you
think that pissed them off
no no the plebeians know their place
down here in the dirt on
earth while the aristocrats fly
literally above us and we should all be
thankful for
the government giving you 10 million of
our knowledge remember sam kinnison you
know
that's why he had this like young
comedian special where he was talking
about uh
someone was filming an infomercial about
the the starving kids in africa yeah
he's like can't the director give him a
sandwich yeah you know so
is that kind of the the same thing yeah
yeah at some point you can make that
argument for
everybody sure who makes more than yeah
yeah yeah like uh
you know uh my mom used to be when
obviously we had poor portion control
growing up so my mom would be like you
know
we were a bit impoverished so you had to
eat all the hot dogs that she was
cooking
you know so uh but you turned it into
fuel yeah yeah yeah so the uh you were
joey chestnut
a little more rikishi but for sure the
uh they'd be like they're starving kids
in africa and i'd be like name one
okay as you're going for seconds and
third
you know the thing about bezos though is
you know he's tried so hard to get away
from that nerd image that he has because
he's a natural nerd and he's a
self-admitted nerd
and he's very nerdy but then he's trying
to be cool you know you can tell he's
just worked with coaches that have
helped him he's got the new girlfriend
lauren sam that's what i'm saying you're
gonna tell me the divorce has nothing to
do with this
that's the shape of that rocket people
some people buy an f-150
right some people buy a car so midlife
crisis is that way
yeah maybe a 30 billion dollar mid-life
crisis well basically
what 57 yeah he's like 57 or 58.
but the cowboy hat and then he's all
giddy so that that nerd part of him
comes out how old is he going to live to
how old do you think that this elite
billionaire class of tech entrepreneurs
with nanobots are going to list a long
time
i don't see i mean i think they'll live
to like 110 120 maybe they might find
some technology that'll just prolong
their life i would imagine that they can
do anything they want
and i don't look at him as a as a
tremendous risk taker other than going
up into space
which i would never have done would you
have done that we talked about that on
pbd's podcast
i would not do it i'm not interested in
space yeah i mean uh
falcon's fury at busch gardens was
pretty big for me i hope you enjoyed
that short clip from episode two
of sports now with tom zenner there's
more where that came from here's another
short clip for you to click on from
episode two
or episode two in its entirety right
here and don't forget to subscribe to
valuetainment sports